bon bah allez nouveau spot très jolie
dans l'ordre et sa bulle dur en attaque
allez allez
ça revient à dire et
les bulles - du coup c'est peut-être pas
un scout
ça vient plus facilement
on peut aller la trappe et en
asie sympa c'est un vélo de course à de
route
à un guidon
voilà
on est bons
coups jean lui travaille donc la marque
ce et sita
qui tapera sympa
donc là j'ai quelque chose qui vient de
tout là bas au fond et c'est de pas le
perdre 10 et 20 kg on va toutes les
bulles la ba ouai plus y'a plein
d'arbres
- cadre
pas les rochers j'espère va trier
patrouille
à l'esat run on attend quelque chose de
très gros au moins quatre mètres du bord
après
ils venaient presque avec la porte mais
on n'était pas loin on attend une sortie
de tron et parce qu'il faut pas se faire
mal au dos le gars bons ballons on a
fait le travail pour un autre parce que
le meilleur l'a laissé tomber dans la
cour et ses contrats dans ce cas qu'il
validera et celui-là
je pense qu'on a encore un arbre qui
bloque
il doit y avoir un arbre dessus
ouais
a gelé
travail de merde
grosses poutres d'acier
bon avantage c'est que ça rentre dans la
voiture on a débloqué pas trop fort
l'objet à la forme très bizarre et si
demain c'était un rail ou la houle a
bien annoncé jusque là une forme très
bizarre et un mois c'est peut-être un
gros cadre
[Musique]
est ce qu'il est lourd ah ouais là il
est dans les arbres là bas il fait deux
fois le poids initial pouvoir trois
moyens bien
c'est un cadre clairement
[Musique]
une boîte de 6-3 mais qui dit non il est
encore neuf presque à temps
c'est un groupe vraiment ce brillant
encore
26 arrêts pour fêter ça
jour
félonne boxing made by kawasaki motors
entre price thaïlande and co limited
donc c'est une corona cuit made in
thailand bayonne numéro de série je
pense
pour elle a déclaré comme retrouvez
donc pour ceux qui ont pas vu la vidéo
pourquoi on des cadres je vous conseille
d'aller voir les copains pour à la main
un écran de faim je t'aime bien sympa on
a galéré là dessus ouais
aa c'est vers le cadre de scooters du
coup c'était à côté c'est plus léger
des outils seraient bien
aux os et le moteur enfin le cas comment
s'appelle
le bloc mois la tare terre voilà c'est
bon ça
ouais elle est vraiment pas vieux ok
sympa ça c'est de la lutte du coup ça
arrive pas trop non c'est pas du jus que
l'intérieur tu passe les vitesses avec
ça adacore si je me trompe pas
encore wen au mas s y m on va regarder
c'est gratuit ce que c'est vrai et
scotty tu joues à quoi tu joues à quoi
ce qui en fait la combinaison dernier à
derniers vivent des artistes noie dans
l'orb
parce que de frein aux îles et pas vieux
joli plat pour l'opel sa part directe
pour l'instant on n'est pas encore dans
l'eau en notant scotti on commence à
ramasser ce qu'on trouve à la surface
presque
voilà alors batista première plongée
dans buzz il ya plein de choses mais il
faut marcher doucement se méfier des
canards ouais ouais c'est dangereux ici
elle est froide ouais on va chercher les
motos la salut à tous alors quand vous
pouvez le voir aujourd'hui vidéo plonge
et
26 pour sa première can et la plongée
avec scotty twitter ouais
voilà donc à béziers toujours en espère
faire des dingueries dont alors oui
comme les deux premières vidéos vous
pouvez allez voir c'est parti pour la
pêche et on effectue
[Musique]
en franchement elle est beaucoup plus
forte que dans la foi
j'ai trop une chaise pliante
aura encore quand oxydes d azote
sa bonne dépollution à sortir de l'eau
et dans l'arbre
ailleurs au
canada il y en a parmi eux
à l'écran mais c'est bien tu puisses tu
parles tu manges
mais c'est quoi c'est d'abord on
s'est trop souvent
oooh jolie
voix
[Musique]
or la commune et bien cela il faut
utiliser le vélo
a
[Musique]
réagi content de fidélité pour les plus
tôt
c'est le
solide à aubiac
[Musique]
voilà on
dans la conduite
avec le petit frère
encore dimon spotify est un fabricant
canadien a tout ce qu'il faut pour ça
vous n'êtes pas fréquente loi ça rigole
pas un accord c'est pas la première fois
qu'on trouve des ordinateurs plus ou
moins entier dont un gardé trois donc
qu'ils étaient les trois plus complet et
c'est très difficile de connaître les
raisons pour lesquelles ils sont là donc
on avait cet ordinateur là donc qui est
un is est un ordinateur de gamer qui
était complet on avait aussi celui ci
donc qui est dans un état un petit peu
plus lamentable et qui est plus ancien
bien sûr est celui ci il a une
particularité puisque comme vous pouvez
le voir il manque la batterie et il
manque aussi le disque dur donc pas de
disque dur interne soit un ordinateur
portable c'est vraiment qu'ils avaient
envie de le garder donc c'est plutôt
bizarre vous avez aussi cet ordinateur
fixe donc qui n'a pas de ram mais qui à
tous les autres composants donc voyez il
reste même le disque dur donc encore une
fois ça écarte une autre hypothèse selon
laquelle il y aurait des données
compromettantes à se débarrasser pour
nous en fait ça pourrait tout simplement
des voleurs des voleurs peu judicieux
qui voleraient des ordinateurs et qui
n'arrivait pas à les débloquer donc
voilà bah écoutez il faut un cambriolage
eshop l'ordinateur où ils veulent un sac
il on leur dit dans il essaye un petit
peu mot de passe incorrect mot de passe
incorrect mot de passe est incorrect
ordinateur bloqué europe à l'eau alors
mais voilà sinon bien sûr pour celui qui
n'a pas le disque dur c'est assez
intéressant c'est assez bizarre dans ce
disque dur peut-être qu'il ya des choses
compromettantes c'est
c'est très difficile à dire voler l'état
ça va être compliqué ça va être vraiment
compliqué je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on
fasse appel à des gens plus qualifiés
peut-être amicaux dont on a vu ces
formats sur comment décrypter un disque
dur qui a été effacé j'aimerais bien
qu'il fasse un petit format sur comment
décrypter un disque diouf qui a qui a
pris l'eau noli
or auraient terrible à
ces dangers des roches et
or
est toi j'ai pu croire là où j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu autre que
pour nous c'était vraiment un plaisir à
tourner de d'allier la pêche aliments et
la plongée malheureusement on s'est
vraiment je les vois là je pense que
c'était notre dernière session de
plongée de l'année avec ces combinaisons
là commence vraiment à faire très froid
et et à la fin on claquer des dents un
grand merci à spotify vous n'hésitez pas
à visiter ses réseaux à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de
pêche éléments